it's very rare that you get to meet
entrepreneurs that are
following and have followed in the steps
that
you followed in in your life and like so
whenever i meet people like you and ben
francis who
is similar age to me who has like
similar life ambitions
um i see it as like this really amazing
rare opportunity
to learn for myself and to ask honestly
like selfish questions
and i saw on your twitter i think it was
over the mental health week period
you did a tweet where you talked about
your experiences with
depression burnout and anxiety and from
what i know about your story
you experience those things in that
order so
i think that's a good place to start
which is let's talk about
depression and the the role that
depression played in your life and where
it came from
and how you've overcome or are
overcoming all handling depression
yeah so interesting actually because
um i i realized when i started to talk
about
mental health stuff even more
interestingly than what you've just said
i kind of realized that
i'd been burying another mental health
problems actually the the tweet was more
depression burnout anxiety
um and insomnia but actually it's really
interesting i did a
podcast interview with a nutritionist
called rhiannon lambert and when i was
preparing for that i was going over my
the fact that i'd grown up fat and the
fact that um
you know i probably did have an unusual
relationship mentally with food and
um suddenly like i was unpacking what
had happened in my 20s and
i actually had bulimia i used to throw
up for like four
to five years not intentionally though
this is like quite unusual but that's
how deeply rooted this mental health
problem was
i would eat something and i would throw
a lot of it
up um my friends would like know about
this but it wasn't like labelled and i
went to
you know specialists in harley street to
see what was up and they were like
medically you're fine so psychologically
there's something there
anyway i haven't done it since i was
about 26 or whatever but
it suddenly occurred to me a few weeks
ago really interestingly
that you know being able to label like
the time i got depression
the time i got anxiety the time i got
insomnia the time i was burnt out
i remembered those moments this one i'd
actually buried as a story
right in my head and never i'd never
expressed it in my whole life to anyone
publicly at all
full stop um and it was a couple of
months ago i wrote a newsletter on
mental health and
uh and nutrition um and i admitted for
the first time then that i'd had bulimia
and like what the symptoms
were and how long it had gone on and the
fact that i was basically like losing
lots of weight getting really skinny and
all i saw was someone fat
um and it was so interesting to me like
two revelations that came from that
one is that um if it's
so uncomfortable right it's for me it's
really embarrassing to admit to myself
that i was weak enough to have a mental
health condition that bad
that i would psychologically throw up
when there was nothing biologically
wrong with me
um that's really awkward to admit to
yourself it's also
far more terrifying to admit it publicly
once you've uncovered it
and it kind of made me reflect on the
fact that um sometimes like these things
are actually just so painfully
embarrassing about your personal life
that you can even bury it to yourself
did you ever understand why you were
bulimic was there because it's a
psychological like comorbidity so
what was the cause it's really hard to
say what the cause was because i got it
after i'd lost weight
um so you know by the time i was sort of
21 or whatever i was in perfectly
reasonable shape
um but i got it at like 23. um and
actually there was a result of it um the
only time i was ever hospitalized
it's a really random but hilarious story
in its own way
um because i've been throwing up i've
been basically like hurting the inside
of my throat right
and i was at a festival one time and i
had a coughing fit in
in hackney and i had a coughing fit at
the hospital and i coughed a hole in my
throat literally it's called a
pneumomedia steinem it's a very unique
thing to happen apparently
and fortunately it was close enough to
the royal london hospital to go in there
and show them right
and basically what happened to me was my
head started to grow so i was with my
friends feeling fine other than this
cough
and one of my friends just looked at me
and was like whoa and i was like what
they're like may your head is massive
i'm like i'm not even talking mate maybe
a dick
no no your head is growing what is going
on i was like what and then
everyone else was like oh my god anyway
walks to
the hospital um it's sort of like five
in the afternoon or whatever because
there's a day festival
um and there's like you know it's east
london there's quite a lot of genuinely
like gang related things people are
bleeding everywhere all this stuff and
they just see me and they're like that
guy's next
and put me and i went into intensive
care for like the whole week um
whilst they were basically trying to sew
up this hole in my throat when you say
your head was
your head was growing so oxygen was
going uh not going
like in my mouth and through my
bloodstream properly somebody was
escaping around my head and my brain
so it was like an emergency procedure to
like like get me on
uh meds and sort me out but it's so
interesting because even
knowing that that had happened to me i
didn't relate the cause
to actually a deeper root cause which
was another mental health problem
um to be honest with you like i couldn't
say to you what the trigger was
beyond this like story you know the
things that we grow up with the people
that we grow up with those little
you know bullying and things like that i
mean you know in some good respects
because i grew up fat i've got a good
personality and a sense of humor
so i've always been like able to really
connect with people because i just never
had it all my way kind of thing
do you know this this story about you
know um people that are fat having
better senses of humor and being a
little bit more you know quote and quite
bubbly yeah
why why is that i think self-deprecation
can sometimes be like a
defense mechanism right and and
ultimately
you know with these things you're going
to hear them a lot if you grow up you're
going to hear it a lot right you're
going to go to a new environment
someone's going to bully you for the
obvious and so
you kind of find a way of coping with it
in your own way
um for me it's just interesting because
the other mental health um issues that
i've had in my life
i'm able to trace back usually to a
moment or a thing or reflect on why
this one kind of just happened later and
then as soon like you know i had it for
a few years
but then it just also went away at what
age was this so about 23
to about 27. are you old now uh 33.
so it was so you had it for 23 to 27 for
about four years
and you overcame yeah but like
naturally i wasn't doing anything
different i mean i started to learn what
foods would make me more sick than
others if that makes sense as well
um but i find it super interesting
again less so i mean we're cool to know
the trigger
obviously but it's almost less so that
and more so the fact
that um it kind of ran its course as
well was interesting to me and that i
buried it
right in my head um and actually 27
um you know was the start of like a
whole other you know experience in life
for me anyway
so it is possible that um you know these
things are related to stress and other
things
um my entrepreneurship journey started
at 24 so it's not
completely unrelated but not quite not
not enough to actually label it and say
it's
for a thing um but then you know the
other
the other experiences um that i've had
with
with mental health a lot clearer so i
think
depression is a really complex term
um and the only i think it's really
worth saying the only
relation that i've got to depression
that i'm comfortable talking about
um is after my father passed away and i
think that's
really reasonable right and so this is
the thing i
like because i work so so much with
people in mental health and experts
i know like depression is also
not something to claim you have when you
feel down or
you know it's very different like and
obviously there is a spectrum of these
things as well
but for me my depressive episode was
right after my father passed away
because he was on life support for six
months and overcame
when they said he's 100 going to die
actually survived
made it out of the hospital into
recovery home and then someone basically
had a cold around him and he died of
their cold catching their cold
after the entire recovery process um the
truth of the matter is that
my depression was actually interestingly
sort of linked with a lack of belief
in um a higher power or whatever you
want to call it justice
like everything right because in
fairness yeah and like my dad was like
such a generous spirited guy
he was blind he had all of these things
wrong with him anyway and still
like was just the funniest nicest
warmest person anyone knows
and um the last person on earth to kind
of deserve something like that
and so for me the um
the experience after he passed away so
he believed in god
so when he died i was like that's my
connection to god gone
therefore i straight up believe in
nothing um
you know i think it's really interesting
to have conversations with people
intelligent people like yourself when
you talk about purpose
and vision and these things it's very
hard to imagine that you've got a
purpose
a vision for anything if suddenly you've
switched
and you've switched off and you've said
i believe in nothing you did totally
destabilized
yeah yeah i remember the the feeling of
being i was religious until i was when i
was christian until i was 18.
and then which i think will surprise a
lot of people because i'm a very
rational
sort of someone that makes a lot of
decisions and things from first
principles or logic
and then at 18 i lost my faith per se
and it was the most like the two years
following that were the
two most destabilizing years of my life
as i i became a total obsessive atheist
which means i read every book watched
every documentary video
and then i got to the point and this is
when i realized that i'd overcome my
sort of
wobble where i no longer cared about
engaging in these debates with people
that agreed or disagreed with me
and i was at peace with my own beliefs
that um i guess which is like
agnosticism if that's a term and the
other really destabilizing moment in my
life where i lost my sense of
purpose was the day someone offered me
about
20 to 30 million um hypothetically to
buy my business
and 18 year old steve shows up i've
talked about this a few times
because he thought we were doing this
for money he thought that was the goal
and so i go home that night i remember
where i sat like it was yesterday
i'm typing rightmove.com looking at
houses at 24 years old
and then i'm looking at these houses and
i'm getting this real sort of
deep sense of um unfulfillment by
thinking well that was
that was it that was the game and then
like okay so um auto trader boom
boom lamborghini aventador i'm looking
at this aventador and feeling like i'd
be poorer
not in a financial sense but in like a
spiritual sense
if i chose to step on what's clearly a
hamster wheel
and and that so from that day the day
after
i didn't know why i was i didn't know
why i was working hard anymore i didn't
know why i was building the business and
i had to then go in
search of a real form of stability in my
life which was
you know i love it but i thought i loved
it for another reason i thought i loved
it for money
but i loved it for connection and for
conversations like this and those things
but to go back to your point please um
you're talking about how
you lost your sense of sort of stability
i guess yeah i lost what i believed in
this world
yeah and if you don't have a sense of
belief it's really hard to find your
purpose
and i i would say that i
i went through a few years of that um
very important age sorry uh so 24 my dad
died so
i mean also similar time to having the
yeah i mean i didn't even realize that
as
i until i was saying it just now um but
so
probably related obviously um but
i i went through about three years
of not believing um
in anything right like really and you
know
not very nice about it either um so i
grew up jewish
um and i've always said in fairness you
know i think judaism is as bad a
religion as all the other religions
you know i don't actually personally uh
like any one of them
but i do love what they all mean but
then you know it's very possible to be
wise and not associate yourself with a
religion
and what i've learned which i find so
interesting
is my identity my connection to
spirituality and judaism is a weird one
as well because it's like a race and a
religion
so it's like you can actually be not
religious you can lose your religion but
still be the race yeah
um and that's that's like an actually
it's a positive in a way because it
means you don't have to disassociate
from cultural values
but you can disassociate yourself from
religious ideals
and what actually happened to me was you
know
i would be relatively difficult
and question people a lot when they
would talk to me about their religious
beliefs
i'd want to dig into them and i'd really
want to challenge the way that they
think and why they think these things
and how they can defend them
but not trying not to be an absolute
[ __ ] but just
using my own i guess bitterness and my
own experience of growing up being told
to believe in something which is very
different to finding something
and you know when my father passed away
and i didn't have this connection to it
anymore
i also felt like i didn't have a
connection to spirituality or anything
and so it's very weird to have like
almost the death of a religion as a
human being
because that's your death of your
connection to this earth and purpose and
everything and
it wasn't until i was 27 really um
one of my really good friends told me
about um and obviously we've been
talking about christian angermeier as
well like our mutual friends so this is
a relevant conversation
told me about ayahuasca and i'd never
heard of it before i didn't even know
what it was
um and i went on a retreat with him and
um i mean i came back that weekend
completely
i mean when i say a 180 i went from
the most cynical non-believer in the
whole
world negatively so to
like without sounding like a complete
[ __ ] like positively
enlightened and confident never never
more confident of anything in my life
um of spiritual realism
and what i believe in and ultimately
what i believe in when i have these like
fun conversations with people now about
spirituality
which is you know what do i believe in i
believe in nature i believe in
looking at the beauty of the world and
how cycles
work which is science right and the way
that my ayahuasca experience actually
opened my eyes to believing in something
spiritual or greater than myself
was 90 percent of my hallucination was
observing what happens in nature with
cycles
right birds bees oxygen air
soil all of this recycling all the time
for a sustainable system and being like
you know that is
in itself a scientific miracle but
something greater than us
that's always happening throughout time
and it was a real shift for me because
a i overcame my depression from that
b i suddenly believed in something
even if that's something is nature and
when people are like and i get this from
christians quite often as well because
they're like you know what do you mean
you believe in nature like what is that
i'm like
i mean it's it's more believable than a
guy that walked on water
yeah and when they like get annoyed i'm
like i've got nothing against jesus i'm
just saying that like
believing in nature as ridiculous as
that sound
is a profound belief and what's
important is it is a belief
and having a belief has actually helped
me helped guide me to then work on
things like
what are my personal values you know
which you talked about you know mental
models
what do i say yes to a no to in life
well you can only figure those things
out if you spend time with mental models
first principles thinking about
what things mean to you in life and then
suddenly
other things start to come into flow and
and so i really want to just double down
on this ayahuasca experience
what exactly did you do on that
experience
so ayahuasca is essentially uh and it's
completely natural it's tree sap
from the amazon um and it's been
practiced for thousands of years and
you know i won't go into like the whole
history of psychedelics but i could do
because i've read a lot about it
um the the reality is it's sacred
so our shamans have like a legal license
to practice with it
um and they it's a guided experience so
the most important thing to say to
anyone thinking about ayahuasca or
whatever like
it's not something you do at home on
your own
at all ever you could do that with
mushrooms you can definitely do that
with lsd
you definitely do not want to do that
with ayahuasca because
um in my experience the other
psychedelics are a bit like you can have
sort of one foot in this world one foot
in that world
and ayahuasca is not even in this
plane you're just somewhere else but
what's fascinating and very common from
people's recollections of ayahuasca
trips is
you have a spirit guide called mama
ayahuasca that's what everyone calls
her um and
in all of my experience of doing it and
i've done it about 12 times now
so i almost go back every year by the
way it's an incredibly painful
experience
and it's very difficult to do and it's
not something you look forward to which
is why it's like
rockish rocket fuel growth um which is
why i do it
because you learn all the things about
yourself you don't want to hear you
don't want to know and you confront the
worst realities
and i've learned more in those weekends
that i've done this then
you know you can learn with therapists
and you can learn yourself so staggering
everyone says this to me and it's
and you know you mentioned a guy called
christian angermeier
context he runs a company called a thai
which are are now
developing um psychedelics as a way to
cure treatment resistant depression
um it's really sort of a groundbreaking
company and he sat with me in his
his penthouse just across across the
street in fact from where we are now
and he was telling me that you can let
you unlock the brain
by taking these drugs and you discover
truths about yourself which
in many experiences which is similar to
what you're describing
will have a permanent lasting
transformative impact on the way you
see the world and it like corrects your
thinking and it's it's
it's crazy crazy for a normal person
that isn't
in this world or doesn't understand this
to think that you can take
a magic mushroom or a drug or a
psychedelic or whatever you want to call
it
and overcome grief there's a great book
by michael pollan called
um how to change your mind and in it he
talks about this problem with
psychedelics it's a bit like dreams
right
you're having an ineffable experience so
to describe it for people was generally
quite boring
what i think is more interesting in a
sense is to discuss
the outcomes that i've i've got from it
um
so the first time you know very quickly
because you asked
the experience was the hallucinogenic
experience like i said was watching the
cycles of the earth develop
and were you conscious because right so
you haven't done it yes so
you drink it it takes about an hour for
me you lie down the pitch blacks fluid
it's like a shot it tastes disgusting
but some people like it you lie back
um and and the shamans basically start
playing music and it's a completely
guided facilitated experience with them
if you're having problems they come over
they help you if you need to be taken
out the room they look after you it's
like
you know it's busy night there's noises
like a lot of people throw up
how's this for irony i didn't throw up
for my first 10 times
which everyone was like that's super
weird i was like yes especially
considering my history
really bizarre um but the
um the experience i saw was the one i
needed and there's a really deep
insightful experience you get from
psychedelics which you can often go in
wanting a thing but it isn't what you
need and in this experience what i
wanted was to see my dad and to connect
with my dad but it isn't what i got what
i got was
um a vision of understanding
how everything in this earth is living
in a cycle
like a beautiful miracle and so it was
less about like seeing
micro things and seeing macro things
being in it
if it's taking me to a place i don't
want to go and a door i'm not ready to
open
you can negotiate you can actually say
i'm not ready for that yet and sometimes
it'll push you and say
open it anyway but sometimes it will
actually listen to you and let you go
sort of back into your body
so it is a really fascinating
experience and what i'd say about it is
it's the number one most important thing
i've ever done in my life
um and especially because
it's not pleasant um the first time i
did it
was you know the single most
life-changing moment in my life
not only got over my depression you know
i went and spent the whole day with my
mum the next day explained everything
that i'd experienced um you know not a
mum's favorite chat hearing your son
talk about psychedelics but certainly is
in context of like helping me get over
something she was aware i was suffering
from
um the single greatest lesson i've
learned in ayahuasca is about gratitude
so i was going through a period i think
i was 30
potentially it was a few years later and
uh
things were going well at the time so my
attitude my mindset was i want this i
want that right what's your intention
going in well i want this
i want that that's like how you answer
it because you're not enlightened enough
to understand
the psychedelic experience right yeah
yeah and you can write it down and come
back to and be like that was what i was
looking for in this journey
um but actually the lesson i learned so
i was asking you know how can i 10x what
i do
how can i be more how can i become
better how can i have more impact you
know
me me me me all these questions um i was
instead transported to
um like basically i'm not sure where in
the world but a very poor part of the
world
where there was this like kid like
begging
in the street basically and i like
became that kid
and i became this person like trying to
get water for his family
and having to walk miles for it and
50 of my whole entire psychedelic
experience that night was
literally walking like a mile in this
boy's shoes and
it this lesson sort of came to me about
you know it isn't always about what you
want
and it isn't always about like you know
asking for more
it's actually about having gratitude for
what you have
and when you have enough gratitude for
what you already have you will unlock
the path to more
and you know there's this thing that
i've learned as well which is when you
go into experiences it's helpful to have
a totem
right so i carry a different stone in
for each experience and i have these
stones at home anyway i have this stone
by the side of my bed um and every
single morning that i wake up the first
thing i see is this stone
literally just a pile of crap stone but
the point is it's imbued with this
message for me
and i wake up every day and i'm grateful
for having running water
in my bathroom there and that is like an
unbelievably poetic
and powerful way to live your life past
an experience to wake up
in camden town in london being you know
so fortunate like i am but with a real
genuine reminder
of gratitude as opposed to like waking
up groggy and being like hey i'm
grateful for waking up today this is
like it means something to me
so these little triggers and shifts they
emotionally change something in you but
i've learned a lesson the hard way
through ayahuasca as well which is
just because you're learning lessons
this is like all wisdom right it doesn't
matter whether you get it from ayahuasca
or you get it from you know your
instagram posts
you can read it and it can resonate and
you can be like wow that's powerful
without action it means nothing so if
you don't create then the steps
to be better based on what you learned
you're wasting
a very powerful weekend and painful
weekend
and i've been guilty of that too i've
learned i've learned lessons
that i haven't necessarily followed
through with and
you know and and sometimes it's because
they take bravery
and i feel like i'm not ready for that
bravery up and so we were talking about
the other day
you know with the exactly with personal
branding exactly actually
that's actually a good segue on to that
topic as well because it's something
that
i know for a fact a lot of people
struggle with in different
forms and um but in but also
specifically with this topic which is
putting yourself out there on the
internet um i know this because
a lot of people have told me but also
because i've
been there right so let's if we rewind a
couple of years in my own life
a guy called ash jones says to me you
should make a youtube channel
i dismiss the idea obviously because i'm
like well people are going to think that
i think i'm
mahatma gandhi like or like people are
gonna think that i think i'm a genius or
that i think i have all the answers so
i'm not doing that
eventually after two years he sits me
down in this room and it took
about eight or nine hours for us to
shoot a two-minute video
because i couldn't speak i i was
self-conscious and all of these things
and i was plagued by that thought that
my friends back home who knew me in
school
will think oh steve's a [ __ ] he's
changed what's he doing who does he
think he is
and that almost imprisoned me it almost
stopped me from
doing the thing that actually liberated
me made me the most fulfilled i've ever
been
and by allowing me to be my like true
self
and in fact what i wanted to do was be
true to myself
and um
it felt like i was worried that people
would think i was um
being something i was not trying to fake
myself and so i guess the question that
i have for you is
you know a lot of stuff but you've not
you know you've got a great podcast
secret leaders you've got a new podcast
as well
which is centered around your brand
heights um
you've struggled to put yourself out
there on the internet and social media
can you explain
why yes i mean such a good question
steve um
but also because we connect a lot on
this right so you're like my unofficial
mentor with a few voice notes where i'm
like
he's got a [ __ ] point here um
so you know it's i guess i'll put it a
slightly different way you know i was
listening to one of your early but you
sent me this actually your podcast with
with him so what was his name ash jones
yeah
yeah you told me to listen to an episode
which i did and you know he was talking
about the early days of social chain
you learned early that you you were
bringing in most of the revenue like
steve was bringing in most of the
revenue therefore the business decision
made lots of sense to center that around
you
i think when you're doing b2b that makes
loads of sense
the challenge i have is um my products
are b2c right they're for consumers
and putting as much time and effort and
thought and energy
into promoting myself is is mental
energy i should be putting into the
brand
and you know there is i think uh
probably a reasonable compromise and
also like all things this is a bit of a
developing
scenario however um you know it's a very
fair thing to say
that i'm not the product this is the
product um
inside my company we could all agree
that that is like broadly true right
we're selling a thing we're not selling
me whereas
you know going through exactly the same
experience at social chain you guys if
you weren't in the room you guys would
have come to the same conclusion which
is steve's the greatest like part of the
funnel here so
we as a company succeed when steve's
succeeding so that's the kind of
marketing final we should back so you
know i can see you sort of
smirking at me because this is the story
i tell myself okay fine
because i was like this doesn't make
this is the story
this is the story that i tell myself it
doesn't mean that it's true um
you know then there's another question
about platforms right so
um you know this isn't a mental health
condition
um but i do have imposter syndrome and
you know we've talked about this in the
past as well but
um you know the first business that i
scaled
uh was grabble and which is when we
first met yes
um and you know that
that was me going into technology and
fashion having had no experience
previously i was in advertising before
and i love changing industries and i
love challenging myself to completely
wipe the slate
clean and do something new but it comes
with imposter syndrome that's what i've
learned about myself right i'm
i'm full of the internal monologue of
i'm not good enough no one cares what i
think and
i don't deserve to be doing this it's
someone else's dream
um that doesn't change
right in me that that voice is still
there
um however you know a really good thing
if you're aware if you're consciously
aware of your limitations especially
like some of your mental frailties
creating steps to improve those things
are helpful so
with heights the first thing i did just
over 100 weeks ago we started a
newsletter
because i was like i'm going to get
imposter syndrome so badly
in a space of neuroscience and nutrition
not neuroscientists or nutrition like
it's going to be
awful for me so i'm going to write a
newsletter every week
and i'm going to read a science paper
every week and i am going to distill
that into three minutes because when you
read something you learn it once and
when you share it you learn it twice so
the process of literally rewriting this
was creating neural pathways
and embedding the information into my
brain so i was like in a hundred weeks
it's actually what i told myself and
it's just
been 101 now um in 100 weeks i won't be
a neuroscientist or a nutritionist
but i will have read over 100 science
papers and i'll know what science says
is good for your brain
according to journals experts etc which
would be an amazing
step to create an amazing habit to build
to get over my own mental frailties and
my own story of imposter syndrome
so when it comes to social media i feel
like i've got the same thing which is
like
um when my last company failed
and i didn't know what i was going to do
next i looked at like my social media
platforms i was like you know
where am i going to spend time rather
than where am i going to waste time
ultimately right because you can get
caught up in
this silly game and then thinking
personal branding where do i feel
comfortable that would be a good place
to start
and i chose linkedin and the reason i
chose linkedin was because i told myself
a story which i completely believe to be
true anyway
which is whatever i do next i'm a serial
entrepreneur right as in
i'm fine not having any money i'm fine
working for other people for free doing
all these things but i'm always going to
start something else
myself again so if i know that to be
true it means i'm always going to hire
people
and what do really smart and impressive
people want from their boss they want to
know who they're working for
they want to know what your values are
they want to know what you believe in
they want to know what kind of things
you share
and so i was like linkedin is the only
place that could credibly do that for me
right
and i actually went from i mean it's not
you know that impressive but i went from
like
3 000 followers or something to almost
25 000
on the basis of and as you know there's
no putting money behind anything in
linkedin or anything
literally just by being myself by
writing about how i'd failed
by writing about what i was working on
next by working and and also all of the
things when you know writing about what
you're working on next is such a
difficult thing to do because it's
probably going to fail as well
and it did you know before heights um
with three iterations of things that i
was publicly putting out there and
getting feedback on and stuff that we
had to kill because it didn't have legs
um it's a horrible time for an
entrepreneur
in between or it can be certainly in
between people like what do you do
and your identity is in flux and you
know you're like do i talk about this
new thing that i've just discovered that
might not be a thing in a month
preaching here dan i know right exactly
exactly
but it's such a complicated answer to
give in the now yeah
um so anyway like on the personal brand
thing like i decided linkedin was a
place i felt comfortable because i can
be my authentic self because i am an
entrepreneur because i
am someone who is willing to go big
and fail and like actually figure out
why and talk about why and i think this
stuff is so
important um for entrepreneurs to
connect
openly and honestly because i absolutely
hate and the one thing i will not miss
about networking events
is like going to them and everyone
talking about them killing it you know
that is
literally poison in our society it's
nonsense
so everyone just talking about how
they're killing it stops people from
saying
actually you know shit's really hard
right now this is the problem i'm
dealing with
and this is like how it's making me feel
if you're able to say that to another
entrepreneur because you've created the
container in the environment to be
comfortable to do so
that person can probably help you and if
you are
stuck with the narrative that
everything's going amazingly
all the time and that's all you're
telling people no one can help you
figure it out when you actually could do
with the help you know it's the other
thing going slightly off piece sorry but
you know my biggest bug bear in
entrepreneurship is stealth mode
i think stealth mode is like the most
stupid thing that an entrepreneur can
claim to be in full stop because as you
know
ideas are worthless execution is
everything anyone that's ever built a
business knows how stupid
it is stealth mode is when people say
like working on a new business in
finance in stealth mode
right i'd love to see i mean not telling
anybody yeah i'd love to tell you what
my startup is but it's so amazing you'll
steal it so i'm not going to tell you
guys
all the time all the time so many people
do it and
and i i i give the most direct feedback
on linkedin
probably very similar to you like loads
of people asking my help for loads of
things all the time and if i ever see
stealth mode on their thing i'm like
i don't talk to anyone in stealth mode
fyi stealth mode is such a stupid thing
because
it's it's it's like how do i describe
like saying i'm afraid of feedback but
it's yeah but it's also like saying
i've got something that i can't tell you
yeah why did you tell me you had
something
i know you know just don't start the
conversation with me i'm a curious
person
what it is but you know you're attention
seeking but you don't want
to tell it's like it's a weird form of
like i don't know flirtation i don't
know um
but i want to get to this point about
why you
we have this conversation yeah like a
week or two ago about
instagram and making videos of yourself
and putting your ideas out there
what is it that's stopping you doing
that you talked about imposter syndrome
i guess that kind of relates to the
business side of things more what's
stopping you
going on instagram putting a video on
your instagram and saying
this is what i think these are my ideas
comment below if you agree
yeah you're it's a great question um
so i guess as a starting point like it's
worth saying that
i think a very healthy way to approach
stuff like this in your life is to to
choose a place build confidence and go
on from there
so i feel like that's what i did with
linkedin i understood that that's the
place where i'd feel
least impostery and so i'd start there
now
you know i picked up on on twitter i
mean twitter is
like my favorite platform that's when i
spend probably the most time on um
but you know it's it's got a very short
half-life so it's kind of impossible to
to consistently come up with gems um
instagram you know to me was this place
where
just beautiful people live young
beautiful people live and that's all
anyone's interested in
and that's not really my world right i'm
interested in challenge i'm interested
in mental health i'm interested in
stories
um and i interestingly i wasn't finding
that on instagram so i was like what am
i doing i don't really belong in this
place
at all um i'd say like a hundred percent
like inspired by the way that you've
approached your instagram like sharing
insights because insights and like
distilling my thoughts into something
and writing them down
that is something that i do i just don't
publish them or i was on linkedin
so actually like what i've now started
doing on instagram is like literally
taking a leaf out of your book
after our chat which is going through
some of my high performing linkedin
posts that you know might have got one
or two thousand likes and being like if
it was popular there
i guess it'll be popular let's have a go
and trying to get over it
now slowly but surely but it's this
constant
belief that no one wants to hear what i
have to say yes
of course and that's what i was getting
at and like where
does what are the forces that are
at play which are making it feel like
some
like psychological discomfort if you are
to
tell the world what you think on
instagram let's say what
in your mind what is it friends back
home is it this particular person
sometimes i can think of a particular
person
and i can think that person from four
years ago is going to think i'm a dick
100 dude like the thing that i've
learned which is so interesting is
90 percent of my fear of what people
will think is based on my school friends
yes who like you know i only speak to a
bunch of them now you know identity is
such an interesting thing and you know
you have it when you're
um you'll be going through it right now
and i empathize right you're not steve
from social chain anymore
yeah right and that's you know for ages
you know i was down from gravel now i'm
down from heights
um you know people do that and that's
fine but it's important you don't over
compensate that identity for yourself
attached to your business because we're
all on a path and we're going to go
through a journey and the journey
the stories are going to change and when
you over attach yourself to a particular
part of the journey
is where you can find struggle and
that's and
on that point you build your life around
that identity so your friends
the you me your music your interests and
so you you would have collected
through your life a bunch of people who
know dan as this
exactly and you're gonna have to shed
some of them potentially
by by stepping into your new identity
100 and that's a i guess a conflict or a
100 and it's difficult right but as you
grow you edit
and you know you need to really consider
who you're editing out of your life and
who you're welcoming into your life
and i think you know there's the the
practical reality that what was good for
you five years ago is no good for you
right now
and frankly you know the highest
leverage decision you can make i'm still
terrible at this by the way
but the highest leverage decision you
can make is picking what to say no to
and the hardest thing you can do is say
no to opportunities that you would
definitely say yes to
so you know that includes friends that
includes saying i don't have time for
this friend anymore
or this identity this part of my
identity anymore
even though i like it i like them i like
all this stuff because
frankly there's you know this
shedding almost that we do as human
beings um
you know the you know in reptile form
it's very physical
right they're literally shedding a skin
but as humans you don't see this change
but it doesn't mean it doesn't happen
and we go in these cycles and i think a
lot of
you know mental health conditioning is
attached to
our holding onto the past and refusing
to sort of embrace the future
and that's why you know i think it's
really important
to set out a clear understanding of your
purpose a clear understanding of the
things you will say no to and won't say
no to
and acknowledging that that changes
right so i do an exercise like this
every year
um and it takes about five or six hours
i do it with my wife it's like a whole
massive
like briefing document essentially on
your vision your purpose your friends
like all of this stuff
um spending the time thoughtfully
thinking about these things which people
do not do enough of
is so important because if you're not
reflective and you're not spending time
thinking manifesting essentially who you
want to be in the future
then i think you're going to miss a
massive opportunity to grow
um you know i because you know i work in
the brain space now
in in brain care neuroscience
you call that neuroplasticity right it's
this idea that the brain will grow it's
plastic and
it's essentially changing in whatever
direction you choose to take it in
if you are episode 53 of chapter two we
talked about this on the last
episode so it's very relevant oh really
okay fine yeah so neuroplasticity is
that
um if you are into spirituality like i
am then it's called manifestation right
it's spending the time thinking about
what you're gonna do and how you're
gonna get that
and then to put it into like super
business terms if you're into business
it's called planning and execution so
there are these different ways to
articulate the same point but the point
is
if you just spend your days going um bit
by bit
not really thinking about where you're
going to go and what it means to you
it'd be very hard for you to make good
decisions and frankly
and this i guess actually speaking like
personal branding a more popular post i
did recently
was about stamina and the things i've
learned about rest which is that
as a founder and a ceo you learn that
you're not paid for your stamina right
you pay
yeah you pay mo gorda for sorry not mo
called mo farah for his stamina right
he's got to run a [ __ ] 10k that's
stamina right that's what athletes are
paid for
i'm paid for my decision making people
invest in me and they invest in heights
for my decision-making abilities and
overworking
giving yourself burnout not taking space
to rest
not listening to what you know to be
true and spending the time planning
that's bad decision-making yeah um if
you can't do those things for your own
body
you know it's like what i said is if you
can't be the ceo of your body
you do not earn the right to be the ceo
of your company you gotta you've got to
look after
your mental state and your physical body
first by thinking
and finding the space carving out the
space to think
what does good decisions look like that
fit my purpose and where i'm looking to
go
and if you can do that and you can
answer those things you actually start
to learn things start to add up
and and that kind of segues back to the
initial tweet where
you talked about depression anxiety
banner and insomnia
so let's talk about burnout then it's a
very
um a very popular topic i actually think
one of the most
listened to episode of this podcast was
the top was the one about burnout
and us being a burnout generation and
how we've kind of glamorized it we're
optimizing our lives so we can fill it
with more things to do
did you burn out how did you burn out
and you understand
why you burnt out 100 um
you know garyvee is a very clever man
um very intelligent but you know he has
created a negative impact on society
that he would probably be upset about
because he seems to be a lovely man that
really deeply cares about stuff from
what i can
see i believe his authenticity but he
has created hustle culture
and hustle porn and you know what i met
gary vee had him on this podcast
and you're right i think in every um
depiction of him there he's a genuinely
authentic person you meet him and think
you are who i thought you were online um
and you're completely right
in the sense that because he's being his
authentic self which we can't
you know uh um we can't criticize anyone
for being in fact that's what we tell
everyone to be be
yourself and chat you know and be
willing to share it with the world
the issue i think as you're pointing out
is his
lack of appreciation that
about nuance and that everyone is
fundamentally different and everyone's
not gary vee i had that problem too when
i started
i couldn't understand why people weren't
sacrificing their lives to build
businesses and working until four in the
morning and sleeping under the desk
i thought everyone that wasn't doing
that was both an idiot and
inferior and wasting their time and
wasting that time and they would never
be happy
because as far as steve's bartlett's
brain could tell him
that was happiness yeah and because like
all of the pain that you suffer is part
of
part of the game and yeah but that stuff
isn't
this is the thing right that stuff isn't
not true you do have to grow
growth is painful and you will have
sleepless nights and all the other bits
and pieces that is part of the parcel
the thing where we confuse this is it's
all mutually exclusive aka
my identity has to be that and only that
because that's how gary v
and like a few other geniuses in society
have got to the top of their games
but here's the thing like there's two
reasons why i had burnout last time
the first was because i wasn't happy on
what i was working and
running a startup can feel a bit like a
cage sometimes so
uh unless you're really sure i say this
all entrepreneurs all the time
are you sure this is the company you
want to build because if it's not
you're going to be doing it anyway and
then you are your own
bird keeper you have locked yourself in
a cage and that's what i did with
grabble
i got lucky i found a niche an
opportunity
it grew exponentially really quickly
millions of downloads had a million
monthly active users in our end we had
like a you know even
acquisition that failed sadly but you
know would have made us millionaires was
a real
journey with that company it was fashion
for tinder basically yeah
exactly and it was a real it was a real
exciting journey but
at no point did i enjoy it um really
like
not at no point my ego enjoyed it right
and we won loads of awards
um you know we won the award we wanted
like we were like we just want to be
written about in techcrunch and all this
stuff and in 2017 we won best mobile
startup in europe over depop at the
techcrunch europas
we didn't even turn up to that awards to
take that award
because i was having such a bad time
mentally i didn't even go to the awards
of a ceremony my friend picked up that
trophy
and took a photo on our behalf i was
sitting at home drinking whiskey feeling
really terrible about myself
um why because
that was living someone else's dream i
didn't care about fashion
um what was the force that made you live
someone else's dream
yeah good question uh a bit of
serendipity in the sense of
um you know listening to users going on
a bit of a journey and the product sort
of developing
and then it getting catching fire before
you really have an opportunity
to stop and say no that's not really for
me
like you were getting dragged you
weren't pulling a bit yeah a bit but
then at the same time like you know
like everyone i'm scared of failure so i
didn't want to be a failure so i wanted
to make it work and you know by hook or
by crook i was willing to like push
really hard to make it work and you know
i look back on my time with grapple and
other than like working hard i was
working against my purpose and i could
feel it and when people ask me i'm
actually like as you know
always to my detriment honest so
i would tell people including the wrong
people including investors that you know
my heart really isn't in it and like all
this stuff
because you know all i had left for
authenticity was to be honest in these
conversations with other people you know
i've just finished writing my book
um not trying to plug it although happy
sexy millionaires happy sexy
millionaire available on all bookshelves
no it's not pre-order um
but there's a chapter in there where i
really investigate burnout and the
reason there's topics like
self-awareness and burnout which
we haven't quite yet properly defined
everyone throws it out there on
instagram oh i'm feeling burnt out
but nobody's like gone down the rabbit
hole to figure out the innate causes or
the psychological or social causes of it
so i just wanted to like go as far down
as i could go
and i tend to believe the depth that
i've got to with my thinking and the
research that i've done
is that you typically get um you stand a
higher chance of burnout in situations
where you are extrinsically motivated um
to do x activity because i view my life
and i think about all the things that i
do
intrinsically like walking i've never
got burnt out walking my dog
or playing with my dog you know i've
never got burnt out um
like reading books that i love and those
kinds of things but
when it comes to getting paid to
do something that i don't intrinsically
enjoy doing
burnout is almost inevitable at some
point not just by now right but then my
but then motivation and i started
looking at motivation and the spectrum
it sits on of on one end being totally
uh extrinsic you're literally doing it
because you're forced to
and then on the other end doing it
because it's an innate passion
an intrinsic passion and all of the
things on this end where you
you're paid and you're forced to burn
out seems to show up
and on the other end when it's it's
intrinsic and you love it and you're
doing it for the sake of doing it
i never get burned out and my motivation
seems to last the course of time so i
wanted to see if that resonates with you
yeah but let me tell you something else
that's interesting that i'm i'm
consciously aware of because i've had
burnout and by the way my experience of
it was you know i just couldn't get out
of bed for a month
really um that was it i basically just
stayed in bed and i just like i couldn't
face going to the office i couldn't face
leaving my
team in the office yeah and you're lying
in bed well i got my co-founder and i
just like
explained that i'd literally i didn't
know what it was at the time i was like
i think it might be depression i didn't
know what it was though this is the
thing i probably didn't even say those
words
how did it feel um just like just no
energy whatsoever just like no
no ability a bit like when i had corona
virus to be honest just like zonked
um not and nothing i was doing was able
to make me feel like i was getting the
energy
i think the reason why as well was um
again i like i'm a helpful guy i really
believe in my greatest superpower full
stop is connecting people right i've got
infinite numbers of ways i've connected
people eight people have got married
that i've introduced you know they say
three in heaven but you know i don't
quite believe in heaven so
it's irrelevant but point being um
you know so many co-founders introduced
i really just believe in the serendipity
of creating
you know moments where you know that
person and that person just should have
that chat
and i force it to happen so because of
that because i really believe in
serendipity as well
um i do try and say yes to people and
help them out so what was happening to
me at gravel was
we were flying we were like number one
in the app store and all this stuff so
the inbounds start coming like thick and
fast right and so i was like
i can't do this the way i was doing it
which is like all over the place
i'll go to old street at 6 00 a.m
every single tuesday and wednesday um
and between six and nine i'll do like
sessions right
if you come meet me between that time
and like your 45 minute slot
i'll fit you in and then tuesday and
wednesday became tuesday to thursday and
then before i knew i was doing it like
almost every single day
trying to be so helpful and it was great
because i i i
get loads of energy from that right like
so much there's
you know great quote of you know there's
no such thing as altruism because you're
ultimately doing it for yourself and i
believe that
um however so it's like find your
motivation and then turn
it but i overdid it and so the result
the net result was like one day i woke
up from my alarm trying to do it and i
like basically couldn't move
and that alarm basically you know kept
going for the next few days and i was
like nope
i just can't do it i can't go to work i
can't get out of bed
it's really like it's really strange
time but
the thing that's really interesting to
me this time right so i analyzed that as
partly burned out and i was trying to do
too much to and
not spending enough time on myself not
having any rest not
being sensible about my personal space
and my life
which was stupid but the kind of thing
you learned the hard way quite often
and then the other thing was obviously
like i was working on a business that i
wasn't very happy and i was having more
fun meeting these people and helping
like make introductions than i was
working my own business
now with heights you know very
consciously aware of the opposite
problem to be true so we just talked
about burnout from some of your insights
right
one of my fears from heights is you know
i won't see burnout coming
because now i'm living my purpose now i
am so passionate
i get so much motivation and pleasure
from working on heights that i could do
this 24
7 um and i diarize
stopping myself right i literally put in
my diary to stop
like all my things rest naps peloton
like all of the things like i talked to
you earlier about like my shakti
meditation these things are in my diary
because if it's in my calendar i'm going
to pay attention to it and i'm going to
respect it and if i don't i won't
respect my own boundaries because i know
that i'm intrinsically a bit of a
workaholic
and if i'm passionate you can't stop me
so i have to stop myself
sure and knowing you know taking
preventative measures towards things
like burnout
if you are happy um i think has been a
really like mature
decision that i'm really proud of taking
this time around because it's a bit like
the imposter syndrome right how am i
going to overcome it i'll write a
newsletter every week great i feel way
less
like that now same thing burn out i
don't feel like i'm going to get burned
even though i've been
sitting in my bedroom pitching you know
to investors like all of february and
march like it's not
a great existence because of lockdown
and if i said you yeah listen
uh i'm the same i'm a workaholic and all
these things i'm an entrepreneur i'm
going to build a big business
dan what is the one thing i can do to
avoid myself getting burnout what would
you
say that is you would say is diarizing
and scheduling time
to do other things like you know i had
near l on this podcast and he talked
about
he writes the book indestructible he
talks about how he will literally
schedule time in his diary to
see his to spend some time with his
partner and take his kids for a walk and
and those kinds of things is that what
you're saying you're saying yeah yeah
i mean i've got um i do have like a list
of habits that i've created for myself
and you know talking about habit
formation um terrible error everyone
makes is like oh i'll listen to dan i'll
do all of these you know habits no i
pick like one new one a year
to be honest with you my number one
mental health hack full stop
um that i say to everyone everyone
always asks me my one thing mine's going
for a walk
um you know spending an hour or so
walking if you can do that without being
distracted i mean
i listen to podcasts and audio books but
i also go for some where i don't take
anything with me and i just go for the
walk
um that's my number one health hack um
because it's not only good for your
brain but good for your body
and because it puts you into there's two
things one we live in london
actually to be honest like gets way
worse of rep about rain than
you know you would think because i don't
go out with a raincoat most days
um but even if it's raining you still go
out and that's a great moment to just be
with the elements and accept that you
know things aren't always perfect even
the manifestation of rain
you know it's a great moment to just go
out and be like things aren't perfect
but i owe it to myself
for my own rest and for my own space to
do this today
and the other reason honestly is because
on average i get to listen to about 50
books a year just by doing that one
thing so as someone who's like a
lifelong learner and happiest when i'm
learning
the amount of books that i've devoured
by stacking that
you know habit onto my daily walk has
been the fastest way to grow
yeah and so we talked about burn out
there the next thing so and that's that
was during your time at gravel
the next thing from that tweet was
anxiety
yeah so the anxiety and insomnia were
completely
linked with each other so a really
really fascinating experience
to me the most interesting of all of
them really because
at the time i got and so at the time i
got insomnia
and this is when anxiety starts to build
because anxiety does go with it insomnia
very well because
uh you start to get scared of going to
sleep which builds anxiety you can't
really sleep when you've got anxiety so
it's like a self-fulfilling prophecy
like every single night so i had
insomnia for six months
and my symptoms were i'd go to sleep at
midnight but i'd wake up at 2am
and at 2am i was wide awake and there
was no going back to sleep whatsoever no
matter what i did
so this was a time when business was
going well i was pretty happy in life i
was getting married
um yes my dad had passed away but my mom
had just recovered from cancer
so i'd had like the whole fear of her
and she's already had it before and
recovered once so very unlikely to
recover the second time but she had i
have a roof over my head i practice
gratitude
you know like i am just that archetypal
[ __ ] that's just too smug for the
world
and i just suddenly
couldn't sleep and i was like i don't
understand
like i have everything that i wanted and
i'm not i don't even want much
you know i've worked on that stuff so
where has this come from
and you know
basically chronic anxiety the feeling of
chronic anxiety
is lots of sweating lots of self-doubt
um lots of um almost like a bit of a
personality
change in me you know outwardly i'm
quite confident but you know this
experience with anxiety was sort of
really making me question everything
about what i say
how i feel who i am and you know
it was in this cycle where if i'm about
to go to sleep
i'm not going to be able to go to sleep
because of this you know these feelings
of doubt
and stories i'm telling myself and it
became this perpetual illness and by the
way i
tried so many things right because when
you say doubt
yeah and the story self-doubt self-doubt
about business
self-doubt about business self-doubt
about who i am um
and about why i'm feeling like this
anxiety is such a complicated thing
because
um you know there's a great uh i think
it's by lao tzu
the it's not a perfect um verbatim
quote but he said something like
depression is a symptom of sadness for
the past we've lived
anxiety is obsession and confusion over
the future you're gonna have and that's
why like mindfulness and being present
is the antidote
and i think i really resonate with that
because you know my own depression
experience was
loss of my father the past my anxiety
was like the person
hey was anxiety about the night i night
sleep i'm about to not have
but also like you know who who am i
going to be what's going to happen
how long can i live like this feels like
it's self-fulfilling in a way as well
exactly so the the truth is i tried all
these different things so like i went to
i did therapy i did sleep therapy i used
all the apps calm sleepio
i tried you know uh cutting out alcohol
i tried drinking
much more alcohol like i tried you know
like you name it i'd like not smoked
weed for a while i was like right that's
it getting a weed habit back
you know like anything that you could
possibly do to just like stay
zonked but i went to the doctor and he
recommended me sleeping pills
but that really irked me i mean we just
talked about lost connections johan
hurry right
um i don't appreciate medication
that will work that night as solving my
problem and i'm smart enough to know
that it wouldn't solve my problem it
would just help me sleep that night
so i've still got those sleeping pills
and i never use them and i kept on going
for this journey the search for why
this was happening and it led me in the
end to a dietitian
which i'd never worked with before and
by the way i didn't even know what a
dietitian was and heard of nutritionists
because isn't that just
everyone on instagram um but a dietitian
uh had no idea but it turns out a
dietitian is basically a nutritionist
with a scientific degree they can work
in the nhs and they work with sick
people
so if you have a sick problem like
insomnia you go to a dietitian and they
will literally
tell you medically what they can do to
affect your
your experience and she just said to me
um
she basically asked me about what i was
eating and my habits and like all this
kind of stuff and i told her and this is
someone who i think i'm quite healthy
generally speaking and she just said
um you're basically not getting enough
brain food and i was like
i don't even know what that means like i
don't understand the context of that
statement and she was like well
let me put it this way your brain is an
organ right
it's 60 fat 90 of the fat in your brain
is this one compound called dha and most
people that come to me
with essentially mental health problems
which is what you currently have
have nutritional deficiencies and don't
realize there are three main things that
i would recommend in your condition
one is omega-3s the other is b vitamins
because again that's for energy so she
explained that i'm having a spike at 2
am
so i need that spike not to happen i
need to have like much more slow release
of b vitamins in my energy supply in my
body every day
and then the third thing was blueberry
extract because it's an antioxidant and
would help make lymphatic system whilst
i slept right
she's saying this stuff to me i'm like
so skeptical i can't even tell you not
only not a supplement taker
um but she's now recommending me three
supplements and i've been given pills by
the doctor and i'm like
i mean like come on how is this gonna be
any better
so you can imagine my complete and utter
surprise when
i took those three things i mean they
were very expensive they were like
medically prescribed ones so super
potent
from you know i think it was whole foods
or planet organic
they were pricey but within two weeks i
was sleeping like a baby and i wasn't i
wasn't feeling anxiety
and when you have a moment like that in
your life and you know this because
you're a deeply
inquisitive person it makes you stop
and it makes you go hold on a second
like
this was so simply solved i don't
actually believe it to be true
this must be placebo this must be
finally my placebo that has caused this
um instead i did what i do i'm quite
nerdy i started reading science papers
because i kind of you know the one thing
i do hate on instagram is like
everyone's a nutritionist everyone's at
this everyone's at that i'm like
i don't want to listen to some guy that
takes nootropics telling me
about like my brain and mental
performance i want to see what
scientists that don't take any credit
actually have to say about this stuff
and i learned
that there are thousands literally of
science papers this is why i did the
newsletter i knew i'd never run out of
content it's like
literally the deepest well of content
ever ever ever to do what i'm doing
um there were thousands of science
papers on all of these ingredients and
how they impact
not just your mental health below the
baseline so if you're suffering from
insomnia if you're suffering from
anxiety even if you've got depression
schizophrenia like
so many medical papers scientific
journals sorry
um about the impact of taking a high
supplementation of xyz or obviously
much more food of that particular
ingredient
and the impact it's had and then when
you're at the baseline
all of these examples about nutrition
impacting your mental performance
so this is things like decision making
focus energy like all of the things you
we want in life right no one wants to
really be recovering from a mental
health problem they want to be
at their baseline and thriving and it
just took me by so much surprise because
i was like well if this isn't
like if this is so well known in science
why didn't i know about it i was working
in shoreditch
at a scaling startup like bearded
glasses hipster [ __ ]
like you know keto vegan like yes i've
heard of all of them
um all my friends intermittent fast yada
yada
this is just like common sense brain
food why is that not a thing that people
know about why is
taking care of your brain not something
anyone's actually talked about clearly
and
actually found a really meaningful way
to communicate
what that stands for and what science
papers do really badly
is like you know when i synthesize them
there's about two or three sentences
that are saying the point but it's just
covered with jargon they're boring as
[ __ ] um so i was like
first step newsletter i will add some
emojis and some lols and make it
millennial and fun and i will get people
to read science papers without even
realizing they're necessarily reading
them so
every week you'll learn something from a
scientific journal which i will link
back to that you can click and by the
way no one clicks it
and you can learn something that science
says is good for your brain every week
and that is essentially how the journey
with heights actually started with this
like realization that something as
you know when you you know the beautiful
moment in life where you can spot
an opportunity so big
and actually solved by the power of
communication and brand
um you know a lot of people say brand
and comms that is
not a market strategy that is not
defensible
i think those people are idiots and the
wrong market because
you know my counter to that is do you
think
that buddhist monks got everyone
meditating or was it calm
and headspace do you think that we
love to run because we watch the
olympics or is it nike getting in our
heads
do you think that people around the
world are doing yoga because of like you
know some ashram or do we actually think
it's lululemon
brands create change in the world
that we want to see and brands connect
with human beings and create communities
and the power of social media and
standing for something
is where brands take something that was
always done before anyway
stick a tick on a shoe it's still just a
shoe like lululemon like it's just like
a little logo an omega logo
on pants it doesn't matter the way that
you express what you do and why you do
it is the thing that has the power to
change
and my opinion and my own experience of
being
you know in that shoreditch hipster [ __ ]
area where you just know about things
like early and trends to have never come
into contact with something so important
that can have such an impact as
nutrition and mental health
nutrition and taking care of your brain
to me
felt like a calling right i've just
suffered for six months
i've overcome something this is all i
want to do with my life
and so you started heights and so i
started heights how's it going
great question we launched january the
6th in a pandemic
well not in a pandemic yet i have to say
you know i saw this on my facebook feed
and um i think i messaged you about
investing in the company
just because it was beautiful i saw the
branding on the website and the way that
you'd done the website and i was like
this team get branding and in the direct
to consumer world it's interesting what
you were just saying there about
comms and like the way that i hear it is
like storytelling and
um platforms um
enabling um
almost democratizing the access to like
build great products now because back in
like if we think about nike shelf space
or you think about the the you know the
power that the unilevers have you're
in fact not the war isn't always
storytelling
and brand or comms it's in fact like
knowing a guy or price points
but in the direct to consumer social
media world brand and
comms and storytelling can win and
product design
exactly in product design which is a
huge part of the story and that for me
was beautiful so i
i uh i was straight in there to try and
invest in your company and
i mean you know you know for a fact that
i've been taking heights ever since
january i think yeah yeah december maybe
what's your experience been as a
customer then i i love it and you know
this is and this is this is where i
really
this is why i always also really wanted
to talk to you today so there is
probably
several people on a spectrum of like you
know devout
um vitamin takers or and then there's
people that don't understand
or believe in it yeah i was that yeah
and so how do you confront the
skepticism because with products like
this
it is hard for the user to establish
cause and effect
and like there's other factors that
might happen in my life that may cause
an effect almost in
establishable so like say i take my i
take the the heights for one week
straight
but in that week i have just the worst
mental health week because of other
factors
how do i know so i guess it yeah it's a
great question
i think there's two parts to this right
so one is um
like supplements deserve a bad rep this
is the most important thing to address
first and foremost because when i went i
was like why is she giving me this like
prescribed stuff i kind of just go to
holland and barrow or boots and just buy
the things that she says there
um it turns out there's this weird
marketing thing in supplements where
you can put a minimum in so there's the
amount according to science that will
have an impact on your body brain
whatever
and then there's a marketing amount
which is way lower that you're allowed
to put in on that product so if you say
like vitabiotics or
you know a lot of products there's an
asterisk on those boxes they're legally
obliged to tell you tiny small print on
the back that
what you're taking is actually a
fraction of the daily amount that you're
meant to have according to science but
marketing wise they can say promotes
healthy this promotes healthy that
um you know my favorite story on this is
probably uh seven seas the biggest amiga
right because we all grew up as children
our parents give us seven cs and you
know that's the biggest amiga three
brand in the whole entire world
now every single day according to
science we're meant to have a minimum
like an rda if you will
250 milligrams of omega-3s right you can
get it from your food or you can get it
from these pills
as a safety net it's essentially what a
supplement is right is if you're not
getting the food
supplement not instead of don't take
supplements instead of eating they're
supplements
so it's like a safety net now that 250
milligrams the minimum you can put in is
45 milligrams
so guess how much seven seas put into
their number one best-selling product
45 on the dot and that means you have to
take seven c's for six days straight
just to get one day's worth of the
scientific dose you're meant to get but
it's all small print and a consumer
doesn't see that and supplements for
whatever reason have been able to do
that so
when we went into our supplement design
right this was the awesome thing me and
my business partner joel
came from a tech background at this
point right we've done user experience
we've done all this stuff and we are
very much into this idea of
because we're not from this space we're
going to win because we are going to
approach this completely differently a
we start with community building a
newsletter and an audience
asking questions to that audience about
what we should do and how we should do
it and can we see how they behave
so here are the things that we learn
most people like a lot of people are
super open-minded
about taking supplements starting
supplements right the problem with
supplements is it can be very difficult
to feel the impact or know they're
working and so like a lot of things with
prevention and well-being in general
it's a commitment to the person you want
to become more so than it is like a
medication which cures a problem and
you're like
oh that got fixed that's great that's
over so
you know we got really fascinated by
this idea of like how can you help
people build habits with our product
design how can we
overcome this problem that supplements
have the you know in january massive
surge loads of people start but very few
people continue
if you can get past the hurdle of
someone trying something your job as an
entrepreneur is to figure out how to
make them a real customer
not just a first-time buyer um you know
you talked about that bottle
that bottle was designed with our
newsletter audience by going into
people's homes
and asking them very weirdly and quite
often the wives show us what you do with
your supplements
and everyone has these supplement
cupboards because we neither of us were
supplement takers before like we even
started this right
so we didn't know what normal behavior
was which means you get to ask these
great open questions which is where you
get the best answers
so like everyone has a supplement
covered reason
they all look the same and what happens
is psychologically and we got told this
the whole time
people basically open their cupboards
see so many that are like broken
promises at the time they promised they
were going to start and didn't continue
i feel attacked yeah they feel guilty
they feel guilty and they're like well i
can't just take the vitamin c because i
said i'd take d i said i take that and
everything else and they're always
separate
so people just give up and you know
there's two things to that there's one
there's sort of like guilt about the
promises that you were like with the
person you wanted to be
and then the second is just again you
know it's set and setting or
you know out of sight out of mind so but
also for me
it's i will complete you completely
right i'll commit to what this person
that i want to be which is
i'm going to develop this new healthy
habit which involves me taking zinc
every morning or whatever
i do it for three days and if you look
at that you know famously but
maybe miss attributed quote from
einstein doing the same thing over
and over again and insanity yeah and not
getting and getting the same results
i'll take zinc for three days
and because i can't see a difference
it's much like going to the gym for a
lot of people although
you do eventually see a difference with
the gym and the great thing about when
you get to the gym is you get the pump
and you use a little bit of sweat so you
think something's going on when i take
my zinc
nothing next day nothing no so it's
almost like a belief
and uh and that's i think what i've
struggled with historically
so here's here's the thing so like we
hear this kind of stuff with heights and
we
we love this because it's like
opportunity right it's like challenging
opportunity
that's how everyone did it well that's
dumb we're gonna do it better so like
our first thing was
um the number one reason most people do
not continue is because they forget
out of sight out of mind so we designed
a bottle that
passed the wife test that wives were
like yes i'd put that on my bedside
table
or yes i'd have that out in my living
room like you've just done right you've
got your bottle there but there's no
other supplements there it's because it
looks nice and because it makes you feel
good because you're looking after your
brain and it's there it's like virtue
signaling
exactly it's actually signaling to
yourself completely i'm the kind of guy
that looks after myself
i look after my most important organ and
this is my symbol of doing that
so that was like an important first step
then you know the capsules themselves
are in like patented clever capsules so
you've seen like there's omega-3 on the
outside
the nutrients on the inside that's
important because
we learned that lots of people take
supplements at different times of the
day ritualizing when you build a habit
is really important so if
we could make these that you don't have
to have them with food like you do with
most supplements
because of the absorption the absorption
happens because the dha omega-3 on the
outside is fat
when this when this dissolves in your
gut the new literally the capsule
dissolves the outer capsule with the
inner capsule at the same time the
nutrients have been dissolved in fat
that is the same effect as what you get
from food
so those capsules have been designed
also around habits to help people pick a
time
and you know a lot of people don't eat
breakfast right and so they just end up
forgetting their supplements full stop
so we did it so that you can start the
same time so you get ritualized like
with by having the bottle out and you
see it
and then the most important part which
is communication
so we actually have something like a
brain health score essentially it's like
an algorithm put together by a couple of
neuroscientist phds
and you take it before you start and
again
we do a 15-day check-in and then before
we send you your next month because it's
a subscription through the letterbox
before we send you your next month we
ask you to take it again
now what happens for most people in the
first month let's be real right
like you just said you know
scientifically typically speaking
this product will last will take three
months for you to feel anything
like all supplements so it's a bit of a
long game right you have to believe in
that
now in the first month for you to feel
an impact
maybe you will because where your
nutritional levels were coming from and
your mental state was coming from
but maybe you won't so how can we help
nudge you there well we can give you
awareness so
yeah so we sent people that this brain
health survey right and you know
self-administering but it gives you a
bit of a baseline
a score at the end of like you know
where you are right now and then we
start sending you
coaching comms like very short emails
and snappy bits of information about how
to take care of your brain that you
might not have thought about things that
are
really small little habits that you can
build in and people
start to read them they have an
unbelievably high open rate because
you've just taken the first step to
choosing to look after your brain
so from that point on why wouldn't you
read the emails of the thing that's
coaching you to
do those habits and what we find is in
the first 25 days or something
like 90 i think it's more than that like
93
of people have improved their brain
health score on a self-administered
basis
from paying attention right not from the
vitamins
not from anything else but suddenly
they're interacting with the brand
they're and they're welcoming a brand
into their life whose sole focus is
about how you can take care of your
brain
you've got all these really interesting
very very respected people
just helping to coach you on your
journey um and that
is such an important part of this
because
you do have the disbelief in the first
couple of months right
and people like to be able to see and
measure improvements and
that's hard to do instantly with
supplements but it isn't hard to affect
how someone feels and help encourage
them to make changes in their own
lifestyle that will make them feel
better that is the brand's
responsibility and that's our
responsibilities that's what we work
quite hard on so where i'm really
passionate about building this brand is
as a community
it started as a newsletter community is
everything to me bringing people
along on this journey of brain care and
understanding why it's important
you know the amount of money that we
spend on skin care or hair care every
day
but nothing on brain care the most
important organ in our body
is so completely normalized in society
to have skin care
and hair care rituals and budgets in
households
but not for our brains and so you going
back to the business side of things
um you started grabbing yeah didn't go
well yeah and you were an estimation of
it you said you know
you struggled with fears of failure and
it failed one i was
when you were talking about imposter
syndrome
and when you and and when you're talking
about some sort of confidence issues
around putting yourself out there
all of those things seem to sit in
contrast to something else you said
which is
that you're the type i think this is a
not a verbatim quote but you said it
earlier on you said you're the type of
person that's just going to keep
starting and you know you're going to
fail potentially
and that seems like someone that's high
confidence and very very self-assured
and is not scared at all
and then the other side of you seems
like someone that is
the antithesis of that so i'm wondering
how you you kind of like content
because i i do believe that you will
save that
god forbid not that i believe in god as
you know now um but you believe in
forbid
yeah i believe in forbid forbid um
heights doesn't go to plan
um reaches its lows yeah that's another
way of saying it you will start another
business at some point based around
something else how do you
find the guts
to keep going despite
failure and i'm guessing maybe it speaks
to your
motivations as to why you wanted to be
an entrepreneur in the first place right
i'm intrinsically motivated by
growth and learning so the way that i
like to think of myself
is oh someone else said this to me and i
just i thought it was so poetic and i
was so impressed with her for using
these words which is like a lifelong
intern
um you know this was a founder she'd
gone to stanford had a really successful
career and then
she basically coming to intern at
heights for a few months and i was like
you know like
i talked to you about i did that in
other companies as well but it was
interesting to me to find someone else
that did that and i was like i mean like
you know i could learn from you rodney
the other way around she's like
i'm a lifelong intern everywhere i go
i'm a lifelong intern and i'm like
i talk about myself as a lifelong
learner but lifelong intern was like
even more powerful right i was like wow
that's
you know it's a real mindset towards you
know
um redefining what success is yeah
because as long as you're learning well
not you i
as long as i am learning i am fulfilled
and i think we all have this like one
thing we know to be true about ourselves
right
um starting a business is super hard
right and you know
i'm like i say not a nutritionist not
neuroscientist had no experience in the
space have never launched a vertically
integrated supply chain
like from three different countries our
ingredients come to from 10 different
countries
because we literally source the highest
quality so the omega-3 comes from like
canada
and the blueberries come from italy like
nuts
but all of that stuff it's so exciting
to learn and like the
the opportunity to learn all of these
things are new
gets me out of bed and so the whole like
failing and starting again
you know that's got nothing to do with
you know confidence or lack of or
anything it's got
absolutely everything to do with knowing
where i'm in my uh sweet spot
there's a term that i learned years ago
that sums it up so perfectly which is
icky guy are you familiar with japanese
guy that's me i'm living my icky guy
right now what is it guy uh so icky guys
japanese term
um basically looks like a venn diagram
on a venn diagram right so you're at the
center
and then the different aspects of things
like you know what makes you happy what
makes other people happy what makes you
money what makes other people fulfilled
it's like ticking off all of these
things
and it's like if you can find that where
you are in the center and you could say
am i contributing to society yes am i
waking up every morning fulfilled yes am
i mentally challenged yes it's like
ticking off all of these things it's
like this weird flower you should
definitely check out for people watching
and
listening to this podcast on youtube i
will put the ikigai graph
on the screen now yeah it's amazing it's
amazing and and you know and i come back
to it all the time you know i had my
honeymoon in japan because of
uh discovering ikigai really because i'm
like so you know
i'm very spiritual yeah well i had a
spiritual wedding in ibiza and then i
did my my honeymoon in japan and you
know it was all it was like hikes and
spiritual searches and stuff and
you know there's another fantastic uh
japanese proverb which is
uh literally translated as fall seven
rise eight but what it means is like if
you fall down
seven times rise up the eighth and you
you we talked about success and failure
just in that moment and you said that
i think you immediately defaulted to
talking about
the purpose which was you love
progression
sort of intellectual progression growth
and learning and
it almost seems to me that one of the
ways to escape from the fear of failure
if you even think about what happened at
grabble the faith you describe that as a
failure
one of the ways to escape from the from
ever failing again
is by redefining what success is
redefining what failure is and it sounds
like you've almost redefined success now
as
growth and learning and you and you
won't fail at that even if the company
goes down
right so this is like it's almost like
you've developed a strategy somehow not
to be able to fail again because failure
now isn't losing the company
it's losing your per losing your way
like you did with grabling becoming
someone you're not and being
extrinsically motivated and
it's exactly that and you know i think
the opportunity
that we all have as human beings to be
creative is to
certainly accept that things are not
going to go on a straight path
but you know when when confronted with
these
like horrible moments of like things
like failure and everyone else thinking
that you're a failure
blow gets softened a lot when you get to
reflect and think about what you learned
you know really interesting experience
that uh joel and i did
after failing was we went to uh business
psychologists
and we had a facilitated sessions over
the course of a week
with the this was your fault that was my
fault i take blame for this i blame you
for that letting it all out right
and then we spoke about you know what
our we did personality tests and we
looked at where our crossovers were and
we had like for the first time a real
clear
view of strengths and weaknesses gaps
and could map out some of the poor
mistakes and
decisions that we'd made that led to
failure and
interestingly like you know rehiring in
in heights this time
the thing that we've had for the last
year before we had any employees was a
set of company values
and hiring processes and all sorts of
like interview tips and hiring docs
based on our values before we hired our
first person we must have had them for
nine to 12 months
because we were so certain of
understanding who we are and what we
stand for
being the company values and that those
company values lead to hiring the right
people with the right mindset and that
those people
are the greatest leverage you could have
as a founder to do less of the stuff
yourself
and enable brilliant people to take it
forward um
i think that's probably the one of the
most important things
i've done in my life with spending time
on company values with a business
partner by
identifying gaps weaknesses and spending
time hearing
my failings from my best friend
so much of what was true um that i
demonstrated a lack of focus
um i'd been overly honest right so i
hadn't picked my moments he's like you
know i appreciate a very like
transparent person but you know but you
know he's like you know you don't have
to like tell an investor to their face
that you don't buy into the business
that they've given you money for like
you could have a filter if things like
that then
this is this this is the behavior was
the most hurtful thing he said
i think the most the most hurtful thing
that he said was that
um you know he felt that i
had um not
not contributed 50 50 right
and that i had like an almost
irresponsible attitude
towards what i was trying to get out of
the business compared to what he
needed to get out of the business and
that was a really meaningful start for
us to decide on the next business too
because what he meant by that was
joel is like a very intelligent person
so he is motivated
by challenge if something is hard to fix
right then he'll find a way to fix it
that is like he'll get up in the morning
for that i won't
um i'm motivated by making an impact and
feeling like i'm having a difference and
telling a story
and impacting people and then telling me
that you know that made them feel this
way that is like all emotion for me
right
here's pure like logic and challenge so
by me
you know constantly discrediting the
work that we were doing by saying things
like that right by
being too open and honest about my
purpose and not putting on the filter i
was
literally without care or remorse
making fracturing yeah fracturing what
he believes in and his ability to
succeed and his ability to tell his own
story about the hard work he put
in and i think all of those things were
true i'd say that it was
60 40 if i was being brutal to myself 70
30 like
you know the success of our last company
on him and to be honest like a lot of
the failure was related to me and i
personally don't regret any of it and i
really don't believe he does either
but being able to say this stuff to each
other with a
letter to all out that then also gave me
the confidence to say like joel came up
with like two or three business ideas
before
like heights and we were like figuring
out what we want to do i was just like
no mate i'm going to do the same thing
again i don't care about that thing
yeah but it's really exciting i'm like
it's not to me right
no one is going to have their health or
mental health impacted that i feel like
that's my space that's where i want to
be
so really really enabled us to just you
know
look at my mistakes of the past and my
character and say if you want to work
with me
you know that i'm going to have to work
on something i feel purposeful about
that otherwise this is non-negotiable
for me otherwise we'll repeat history
and you've got another partner in your
life which is your
uh your wife um when did you get married
what age
uh well two years ago i got married two
and a half years ago when did you meet
her
ah well uh do you know the story at all
no i don't know okay fine fine so
technically speaking i met her
at 18 on the khosan road for one night
uh but i didn't sleep with her
uh in thailand okay um in bangkok i
didn't sleep with her but
i tried to chat her up and stuff and it
was a straight up no right um so she's
she was best friends with my business
partner joel's
sure best mate a cousin sorry so anyway
the point being
um that's how we met her originally and
i'd like you know sent some very awkward
facebook wall messages when that was a
thing like you know trying to chat
over the years it was always annoying um
and then at like
30 or 31 like on my birthday um
joel basically reintroduced us and i was
like i'm having a party why don't you
just come etc
and she's older than me right she's two
years older than me so i was a bit like
you're 32 i'm 30. you're a bit too old
to pick right now your mates are married
i literally gave her all the banter i
was like your mates are married you're
running out of options i'm still
available
you know let's do it you're not going to
do any of that yeah
she found it hilarious anyway she did
she did um come join me at drinks and
like the rest is history and actually
our relationship's been super
interesting because
we spent the first year um not
monogamous
um we spent the first year openly so we
spent the first year
openly communicating that we'll sleep
with other people but they were all like
more like one night stands
whereas we were like coming back to each
other which was interesting because
she's just like
hilarious really good fun really funny
and so
i enjoy hanging out with her but it's
very clear like you're not my girlfriend
and she was like great i'm not your
boyfriend no problem we did that for a
whole year
why were you saying that why were you
not um yeah because i like loads of
reasons like one is like i'd come out of
a horrible relationship the last time
where i
i wasn't treated particularly nicely and
i just didn't didn't make me want to get
married
for sure um and i told my mom and her
that i wouldn't get married
incidentally um so i was like i don't
believe in marriage and i don't really
believe in monogamy
and like those are my beliefs i told you
about this book sex at dawn i highly
recommend you read it
so i had been telling myself the story
that this wasn't going to happen so you
were rejecting her
kind of in a way and protecting myself
absolutely um
and you know i think that was mutual for
whatever reason for for a year
and actually after a year you know we
had that awkward conversation i almost
like where she actually you know said
like what are we gonna do like this is
getting like a bit silly now
you know i'm getting on i'm like 75 now
i need to get married
um and um and so i said you know i
almost said no
they there and then i said let me sleep
on there and i was about to say no but
then all my friends were basically like
you know she's literally wicked like why
on earth would you do that to yourself
like what have you got to lose
and from that point of saying yes and
being in a relationship with her
i proposed to her the like it's six
months later and we got married a year
later so it was actually a really short
relationship
you're on meeting to marriage you you
met when you're 33 now yeah you met her
at 30. yeah
so you proposed when you were 31 yep and
okay so you've been together for two
years now yeah and
so i always find it super fascinating
when i meet an entrepreneur that's super
busy and you know in love with their
business and their ideas and and is a
workaholic on
to some degree how they manage to keep
their relationship balanced because
i haven't figured it out yet yeah and i
i take the faces that i've gone through
different sort of levels of immaturity
in my life so
the first phase was um meeting great
people
meeting a great girl and thinking to
myself you need to wrap your life around
me
i'm not going to change a thing about
myself i'm the most important thing in
the world the world
revolves around me you're welcome to
join the orbit
but i'm not going to change at all
didn't go well
unsurprisingly and then like trying to
find a little bit of um compromise
somewhere in
me um but still being ruthlessly
apologetic didn't go well
um and now i'm at a place where i'm
currently single completely single
and i need the answers i i'm less
i don't want to be one of these [ __ ]
[ __ ] narcissists that i just read
about one in the newspaper
i won't say any names martin sorrell um
and
what i've what i read about people i
think it was his ex-wife that described
him
was very very similar to the behavior
that i'm exhibiting which is this kind
of self-centeredness
that excludes everybody but ultimately
will run the risk of actually being
self-harm when i make myself lonely and
miserable
um because i don't appreciate the value
of a relationship so i want you to help
me with the answer
well let me tell you i told myself the
narrative
that being in a relationship i don't
have time to be in a relationship right
um that's my narrative um
being married and all of these things
will close opportunities down to me
and my life will be worse for it um and
that's fine
those are stories and like everything
you know we convince ourselves of all
sorts of stories
and i do believe in you know finding
um not just the one but ones
i really don't believe that there's one
person for you in the world i believe
there's many
and i think having a spiritual
connection with others and you know for
some people like a sexual connection
with multiple partners i think that this
stuff is
totally acceptable a b completely
biological
like biologically scientifically more
normal for us
than monogamy which is essentially
because of christianity in the world
and and frankly you know even though
it's not what i do with my wife
currently we've had conversations about
you know in
five years or in ten years right if we
weren't sleeping together because we
weren't finding ourselves like you know
sexually attractive or whatever at that
point you know
would we consider having the
conversation like opening up our
relationships
huh can i ask you that question yeah
yeah i'm not answering it almost now
which is like yes we would
we would do that and would you be
comfortable with her sleeping with other
men
that's very different question because
uh right now no
future me maybe um
logically right logically if i took
emotion out of it
absolutely because if i didn't want to
at that point
sleep with my wife it would not be fair
to deprive her of sex because of how i
was feeling
and so i think having a maturity towards
your relationships and to all
relationships
is so important and a lot of
you know what really upsets me like so
many people get divorced
um one of the most common reasons people
get divorced is because they cheat
and you can avoid that by having a
conversation like i still love you
and i still think everything i already
always did think about you
but for whatever reason the sexual
attraction has gone and either we are
going to work on that together
or we should explore other options and
like everything in life steve
the most uncomfortable conversations are
the ones you need to have
so i think a really smart way and i
would say this because you know i'm
doing it
but i think a smart way to approach your
relationship is like you approach your
business
so you set out a vision for your
relationship
and you say this is what we want to be
and where we want to be in 50 years
what does that look like um you know
recently
i did this with my wife we were in
portugal we were with some friends
i told you i was working in portugal for
a month during lockdown um
we were staying in like a villa with
some friends and like we'd kind of been
okay in lockdown but like now she's
around other people she's being a cervix
snappy like
kind of [ __ ] we were just getting on
each other's nerves and i went for like
a long walk on the coast with her
and i was just like where's this coming
from like five wise right why are you
doing that why are you doing that but
why are you doing that right
and we got kind of got to the crux of
the issue um
you know these are things that i'm
annoying about and what i do that
irritate her and obviously like these
are things you do and it's like okay
let's take a break from like
right now the things that are annoying
us about each other
let's flip the script in 50 years what
are the things that we're going to be
saying
doing and believing about why we love
each other what does that look like
so like literally let's imagine in the
future how we are and work back from
there
so objective right a long happy and
fulfilling marriage
so you know you might be familiar with
okrs so objectives and key results
we implement them at heights as a
startup but also melissa she's the
um director of operations for europe
middle east and africa for vice
and she put okrs into vice so
we're both fan of the system right and
the system is literally this is the
objective you're trying to get to these
are some
measurable key results that would have
to happen for us to achieve the
objective
so we decided to try and apply this
framework to our marriage
right what is the objective a long
sustainable happy and fulfilling
marriage
what are the key results that get us
there well we broke them down into mind
body and soul
right and from there you get to cascade
down these key results right so
they start to say a little bit like okay
so mind for me meditation is really
important for her
you know she doesn't really want to do
it but like from a compromise point of
view because she knows that i believe in
it and stuff she'll do it with me
similarly you know from a mind point of
view she wants to be heard
right so how about um you know
we will ask each other how our days are
but systematically as a habit
right we'll build it as a habit another
one was you know we'll teach you some
each other something new every day so
we're always growing
these kinds of things literally became
a habit tracker list that we fill in in
our journal every single night
did i teach melissa something new today
did i
um ask her how her day was did we have
sex
were we intimate right were we cuddling
and you know spending time did i have
personal space because really important
to have space away from your partner
these literally become habit trackers
that if you think about it really
methodically
you know did we exercise for 30 minutes
a day these things
if you do them you know the compound
gains of the results you get in a
marriage if we're literally doing these
things together
if i'm asking how her day is and i'm
listening if i'm
spending time like learning something
new to teach her because i want to and
she'll reciprocate the same
it will literally create these moments
where we're not in our work
and we're not doing other things we're
doing this with each other and they
don't have to take very long
but they are like things that we've
taken personal responsibility for
to achieve it's it's people some people
a certain type of person will listen to
that and they'll think to themselves
how robotic how robotic and you know i
had the same conversation with
near il who came on this podcast yeah
and he's the king of this stuff right
yeah and he talked about how he
literally schedules time to be with his
wife and to
you know to see the kids and to play
with the kids and a certain type of
person listening will think well that
takes the
specialness and the magic and the
spontaneity out of just like living and
being you know
free to go in whatever direction and it
also
when you listen to that you that you
start to think about how
us as humans have over
this is potentially a thought over
organized and over routine and really
over thought every facet of our life and
one of the things that i
have a sometimes a bit of a visceral bad
reaction to
is like and you would have heard about
all this stuff that you know the 10
habits of highly successful
entrepreneurs you got to get out of bed
drink the green tea do the yoga write in
your diary do 10 star jumps then
call your mum until you love her and and
it gets to the point that it's one of
mine to be fair
yeah every day if you listen to all of
this stuff
your day would literally be completely
unconscious it would be what's the next
thing in my list of how to be a good
human
and so how do you kind of contend that
rigidness
with creating space for lack of
rigidness and just [ __ ]
seeing where the wind takes you is a
great question in my experience so far
this particular bit of rigidness has
created more space not less space for me
interesting
um and the reason is because if you
think about
the opposite of this right so if you
don't do some of this stuff if you don't
i mean there's so many examples that are
like filling my head right now so
if i don't ask my wife how her day is
regularly if i don't exercise regularly
if i don't you know meditate every day
this is me personally right
okay what are the outcomes of that my
wife is not going to feel listened to we
might end up in an argument how much
not how much time does the argument take
up how much mental energy after the
argument's over
is going to distract me from all the
other things i could do that day right
the things i wish i hadn't said
like all of the things right call that
day a write-off maybe a couple of days
right that takes up loads of time
if i don't meditate every single day i
have a very loud mind i'm much slower at
making decisions in general right so it
is actually taking up more time to not
build that habit in for myself but don't
go for my daily walk
personally a i'm not making time to read
listen and learn so therefore my
personal growth as a human being is
slowing down because i really believe
that
you know the way that i can build a
better life for myself
is funneling wisdom into myself choosing
what i
read and choosing who i listen to and
choosing what i believe to an extent
right
i love reading counter views to stuff
like i'm a lefty i love
i follow loads of conservatives and
right-wing republicans because it's
healthy for me but i'm choosing to
funnel stuff
into my life so again by not doing that
i could be more aimless and more free
and i wouldn't necessarily be following
the path to making better decisions as a
human being which also speeds things up
if i don't call my mom every day she
will call me up and ask me why i don't
love her which will make me feel like
[ __ ]
for three days so i actually find that
this stuff in
in my you know again not exercising you
know you don't have to ritualize half an
hour five days a week like i have in my
diary
right but if i don't i actually start to
feel
achy i start judging myself you think
about these things like actually they
create time they don't take away
um in my experience and that's exactly
what nier said which is that
you know he's he's planning his time so
that he has more time to do the things
intentionally that he wants to do i my
last question on the relationship point
is about bringing your problems home
and how you've kind of because this is
one of the big problems i have as well
is
along with the like selfishness around
my business being the most important
thing sometimes
is how do you
not bring your problems home but then
also like
not make her feel lonely when she sat
right next to you
by being off with the fairies and you
know i was reading
um elon's book the book written about
elon musk and it talked about how he
would you know come home and be
you know a little bit of a recluse even
though everyone's around him and he's in
his head and he's just focused on his
problems his life he's working
incredibly hard to the point he's
sleeping on the floor how have you
managed to find the
balance in the relationship um is it
just the
okay ours is there does she unders does
she get it yeah
i think i'm lucky like a she gets her
and b she enjoys her personal space
and she's super busy as well and she's
super busy as well right yeah exactly
and we have you know she's got scale up
she's running a big company like she
only reports the ceo so she's got a lot
of responsibility
does sometimes it go in the opposite
direction as well where you're not
getting enough out of her in terms of
attention no i think we're both really
lucky like we both like our own company
and we both like each other's company so
you know you can kind of be happy either
way
if you're lucky enough to learn what you
like
and how to be with yourself which takes
quite a lot of learning a lot of us are
very dependent on other people
um and if i was still completely
dependent on my wife's attention and my
wife
like in general then i might be like
that but i've come to learn
you know how to listen to myself how to
make time for myself
how to spend time enjoying being on my
own as well
and i think that's a really important
skill to learn because otherwise i think
the answer would be true
and i think you know she's got the same
which is you know
i'll listen to podcasts about
performance and habits and stuff and
she'll listen to case file
on repeat oh my god is she a case
firefighter oh man if i hear that
australian pricks
absolutely one more time oh my god i've
listened to every episode
there's a uk one called they walk
amongst her i'm obsessed with true crime
yeah so
is she so obsessed well listen it
doesn't work out yeah exactly
exactly yeah yeah she makes me watch
true crime stuff on netflix and it
freaks me out
i have this really bad habit of because
i can't sleep without listening to
something
yeah so i'll be it'll be 2 a.m in the
morning just got in bed with my partner
or whoever i'm with
and i'll say do you mind if i just put
on a
a murder podcast yeah about like a
serial rapist yeah
and then like every single i keep asking
the question but the answer is always
saying
steve babe it's 2 a.m i don't want to
listen to
a story about a serial rapist right now
while i'm closing my eyes in the dark
[ __ ] so i i get my phone or my airpod
and i put it in one ear where they can't
hear it
and that's how i fall asleep yeah so
she's exactly the same and she like
she you know we actually i mean it's
i find it so interesting you know she
will make me watch these things on
netflix
because she's like but it's so
interesting right but actually they
really they actually quite damaged my
mental health because
you know you see things like you know
but that husband loved that wife so much
like why does he end up killing those
two daughters and his wife oh you're
talking about america
yeah the most recent one but like
there's you know all of them you know at
the end of the day like
why someone goes from you know lovely
and
humane and kind and wonderful and all
the things i like to believe about
people in the world
to that terrifies me really so it has it
has
and this almost what you've just said
then sent my mind back to the start of
this conversation about
religion and belief and purpose and and
what you know before when i was holding
they're usually religious even more
terrifying yeah yeah but this
the reason i find it so fascinating is
because it gets to the truth in human
beings which is something that i know
we're both deeply interested in
which is like finding the true nature of
humans and in the example we've talked
about there in america murderer that by
the way because i'm such a nut i'd read
that story i'd watched documentaries on
it three four five years ago
so seeing on netflix and their depiction
of it was fascinating but there you have
just the perfect
perfect example of how um unboxable and
unpredictable
human nature can be when forces like
infidelity and love
and um a normal person the fact that a
normal person can go from being this
lovely dad who was quite placid
to smothering his own children and an
affair
teaches you something valuable about the
nature of being human
and um and for me that is like awesome
that is awesome oh and and that's why i
think i'm so obsessed with those things
is they teach you
the lessons in a violent emotional
gripping way about the true nature of
being human yeah i mean she feels the
same way whereas i'm just like
you know it just plays on my mind really
it plays my mind to the idea of like
well that could happen to me then
that's why because i'm like i'm so kind
loving
you know full of you know good energy
but so was that guy
in that example so was that guy so so is
every review of what that guy was like
from all of his friends and everything
else so
how can that happen to a person and this
is the fascinating thing which
for sure he met someone else clearly he
was he was he was in a marriage
which had lost its passion yeah a
loveless marriage he decided to stay
probably for the sake of the kids he
decided comfort over a decision which he
probably should have
uh made a tough decision which he should
have made in the short term for the long
term good
and it caught up with him and for me
that's like isn't that life where you
suppress
making a short-term tough decision but
that comes back to exactly what i was
saying right which is
yeah that comes back to the relation no
it comes back to setting
a vision for your relationship and you
know having a plan
and talking about in advance right you
know if you're really smart you'll talk
in advance what happens if one of us
cheats
what happens in this scenario right what
would happen if we fell out of love
and you know there's no point like you
know planning the perfect life if you
don't crisis plan the things that happen
to all human beings
and if you've got a great relationship
with your partner i think it's so
valuable to treat it like you would your
business which is
scenario planning spending some time
talking about what would we do in this
kind of crisis and how would we behave
because by doing that with my wife like
i you know we've got permission
to bring up that horrible conversation
right like in theory that that would
never happen to me because if i
wanted to cheat on her i'd have the
conversation with her and i've got
permission to have that conversation
because we've talked about it
i thought you meant that like i want to
murder you tonight
conversation no i probably wouldn't tell
her it'd be a nice surprise
um but you know what i mean isn't like
you know there's permission in our
relationship to address the difficult
things
and that's why in some respects you know
i treat my marriage like i treat my
business which is
you know something that i deeply care
about if it's successful
and everything that i put into my life
is about making these things successful
to the best of my ability
and what i've learned is doing those
things from a sense of
vision and clarity and communication and
values as well because you're talking
about transparency and you know
honesty and exactly i i am as a
when i started dating you know i was
like 18 years old whatever
i thought that i was looking for i had a
checklist if you said steve
what's your type i'd be like okay the
brown hair the this that this they want
to look like this they want to talk like
this
and this list was almost like it was
endless right of like little specific
superficial things i was looking for in
a partner
and after a couple of you know bad
relationships and bad experiences and
maturity and self-awareness and
understanding myself
i got close i was like what are the
fundamentals what are the like the
unnegotiable things
that i can't be without and where i'm at
now and i kind of want to get your take
on this and see if
it resonates at all with you is i have
three things
that are like fundamentals that i need
to fill so the first one
i've kind of defined as they need to be
intellectually stimulating to me which
you can say you know
being able to have a conversation being
able to um
yeah like release my mind or else i'll
almost i feel like i'll get a mental
um disorder if i can't release my
thoughts because you know we're very
similar people in terms of our cognition
the next for me is sexual attraction
i used to think it was like they they're
pretty they're hot but i realize that
sexual attraction is much different to
be than being pretty in
the mind of the world and the third
thing is um
i would hope that they would make me a
better person
and you i'm that's intentionally broad
that could be a spiritual thing it could
be
helping me become a better ceo in my
business better at my podcast or
whatever
so those are my three things
intellectually stimulating
sexually attractive and they make me a
better person however you want to define
that
what are yours well i have to say
sexual attraction is such an important
thing to me in general
but what i've learned is and you learn
this a lot the more you read about
relationships
that is actually something that wanes
for everyone
doesn't mean it will go and it doesn't
mean you won't be attracted to your wife
or your husband or anything like that
but it wanes and you as a human being
become less sexual the older you get
right that's just biology so
i've learned not to make that one of the
most important things on the basis of i
wouldn't say it's the most important
thing
purely on the basis of um i'm more
likely to fall out of love with the
person that i'm with
if one like you just said
they don't intellectually challenge me
second one
again like you said like they have to
help me grow in some respect or
certainly be with me on the journey
because
in a you know in a lot of relationships
including my
marriage like i am the one forcing a lot
of the growth
but i'm like that and i can be quite
irritating to be around because like i
just always want more growth more this
more that that book this podcast some
people just want to
chill out and that's good for me as well
right as in that is growth
being pushed back and being like exactly
dressed stop here
you know she's the one who's like you're
doing too much you've got to stop like
read this book i read an amazing book
called rest
by alex song yam ping i think his name
is um
brilliant book much better than why we
sleep and all the other ones that you
would read about this stuff
and really really helped me grow by
realizing
recharging is such a humongous part
with that third point and like think
about it it was a it was one person i
was with
that would stop me working yeah and she
would make me realize the value of
everything else but work
so she'd be like let's go to this garden
which is something
steve would never usually choose to do
yeah but when she took me my life was
better
and so i think when people think growth
they think oh like clapping at the back
when you're
i'm like no take me out of my world and
show me something else that'll add value
to my life that i wouldn't ordinarily
pursue
and how much more productive you are as
a person as well when you've got space
and time and you've had thoughts there's
a reason why
thoughts come to us in the shower or on
walks right it's because
you're literally scientifically speaking
your default mode network your dmn in
your brain is being activated by that
moment of rest
so you know it is neuroscientifically
true there's loads of studies on it but
it's hard in the moment when you're
people like us
to take the rest and so having like you
know a partner that's there that forces
it on you
as a culture like you know almost every
single evening now i don't do any work
which is so different to me but like
last night we watched the mask
together right like we will watch
something like you know trashy fun
whatever but it's like
not work laptop down we're eating dinner
we're chilling out and it's like a rule
and you know i have to have a very good
reason to break that rule and it's made
me a happier healthier person but
you know without that guard rail i would
just carry on working
and you talked about the sexual point
there i want to say a very personal
story that i've never shared before
about why that made
my made my list and this is a dynamic
list that's changing as i mature
i met a girl that was the other two so i
met a girl that was the most
intellectually stimulating person i've
ever met she was actually a model so
she's absolutely gorgeous
she's also like a just a genius and she
she challenges me with a
sense of like like she doesn't care who
i am or what i've done in my life or
what i've achieved
um and so that made me a better person
she was an absolute genius
and she was gorgeous went to have sex
with her after
you know two months of you know
fumbling hot air balloons and all of
this stuff
i'm really hoping she isn't listening
but the whole point of this podcast is
to be honest so
and it just wasn't there the first time
ever in my life and i experienced
what i can only describe as a feeling of
like horror
um total disappointment not with her or
anything like that
but that that was the thing yeah and it
felt like such a pathetic thing to stand
in the way of someone that i thought was
perfect
so and i got out of bed i tried again i
tried again i tried to get over a couple
of days and i realized that
it wasn't there and i got out of bed and
i remember a text my best friend i said
i could never see her again because this
is something that
i didn't realize is actually so
important to to a relationship even
though it sounds pathetic when you saw
they weren't good in bed but they were
perfect in every other way
it sounds pathetic but it was the truth
and that's what made my list
my other my other thing is sense of
humor
yeah so you know one of our company
values is have a sense of humility
a sense of humor and humility because we
jam sort of too and in the same one but
i believe so strongly in that which is
work can be very serious life can be
very serious
um but finding moments to connect
and laugh i mean so good for
your brain but just so good for your
soul
um you know spending
every day with my wife in lockdown right
you know just us two etc etc like thank
god we make each other laugh
you know like we we have we both have a
very similar very dark sense of humor
um you know one of our things is
actually um
my when we fought on our first date um i
brought up my dead dad
and how actually one of my favorite
things to do in like social situations
is to bring up my dead dad to make other
people feel awkward
um just like because it's like kind of
funny anyway she was like oh my god i do
that about my dad and it turns out that
her dad had died like a year after mine
or whatever
so we um as like our second date or
something we decided to go out on
father's day
together without our fathers and
everyone else just had their dads around
we went to the hoxton hotel
and they came over they're like would
you like the father's day menu we're
like i know our dads are dead thanks
and just literally like found it the
funniest thing that only us two would
find so funny right because it's just so
uncomfortable for everyone else but
to ask that kind of like dark humor like
ways to connect and like weirdness that
other people
it's like you're connecting on your pain
as well because people
[Music]
yeah and like how many of like you know
comedy greats are you know coming
suffering
yeah not just suffering but also coming
from huge places of insecurities as well
and
that's their platform to bring on so i
think those things all really match up
but
by 100 i think you know finding someone
who makes you laugh
and gets your quirks so so so important
because humans are weird um i think it's
lovely if you can be your fullest
weirdest self in front of other people
are you happy yeah i was thinking about
this question
um the other day someone asked me two
answers to that
one yes i am happy like the the blunt
answer is yes i'm happy because
i'm fulfilled the good question isn't it
yeah but i know that's your body body
language
yeah because because because the
question that i asked back to this
person was
i am happy but why is happiness so
important
like why is that the question you want
to ask me like is it does it matter that
i am happy
is it binary yeah and is it binary but
like why does that matter to you and why
does that matter to me
because i think a much better question
is am i contributing
um you know am i fulfilled
and am i contributing because if i'm
doing those things i'll be happy
and i know that to be true whereas for
me asking that happy is a bit like you
know
binary it's yeah and it's like straight
to the point and it's like there's
nothing really behind that it's
undefined as well
undefined and also like really depends
on what you're asking me that day i will
be like no today i'm not happy to
if you ask me if i'm contributing to
society and does that make
fulfill me yeah and make me feel like
i'm living my purpose
it won't matter what i feel like today
are you fulfilled very but i have so
much more to do
i i one of the real fascinating things
that i've learned
um is and i again i've read about this
at length in my book
is how binary questions like that are
the cause of so much pain and no one
realizes it
that the cause of so much like
misunderstanding pain and
um and anxiety so like another great
example
is if i asked you now if i said are you
in love
and immediately you have a bunch of
problems there first you've got to
define in love
no one's ever told you what that is
they've never shown you it no when you
were born they didn't say okay down if
you ever feel like this it's in love
you've got it from instagram and movies
so you over immediately have to overcome
that
and then you have to try and understand
if what you're feeling for this person
fits into that box
and and i think one of it's so crazy
that
especially from what i do on instagram
and putting myself out there tons of
people send me their problems
and usually it's because they they're
trying to fit into a binary box
and they don't even realize that like
steve i'm not sure if this is
my passion i'm like that is a super
binary thing it either because
have you found your passion that that
presumes a yes or no answer
whereas if you say you're like are you
feeling fulfilled it's a much more
it's an answer that appreciates it's a
gradient and not just a gradient but a
gradient that different things
impact yeah so you know i mentioned
contribution like you know
there's many ways to contribute and you
know being outwardly successful or
building a company or
you know you know having a high-flying
career you know
they don't tick that many boxes in terms
of contribution a lot of contribution
comes back to what you do
for society for what you do for your
family for what you do for people that
you care about you know
that stuff is a much broader
question and it's like a cup that's
never full
right so it's nice because it's got
different levels and you kind of know
deep down if you feel like you're living
your purpose and contributing to the
level that
would make you proud and you also know
when you're not which is great because
again it's not bad that you're not it's
just like well i could actually improve
some stuff by giving it some focus
and i think that's why you've got to
continue to like question the question
as much as you try and answer the
question sometimes
are you scared of dying great
question um why is it a great question
great question because
um i don't believe in fear of death fear
of death
is literally um like illogical because
fear of death is what actually makes you
fear of life
so if you're scared of dying then you
approach your life in a very different
way
and actually the greatest fear that we
should have is not living your life
in a true way so no i'm not at all
scared of dying
um it's also really worth saying that
like ever since doing ayahuasca like i
100
convincingly believe in things like
reincarnation soul
spirits other planes all of the woo-woo
crap
that just like sounds completely bizarre
for me to think that i would ever say
those words
it's not even is it from like a
scientific perspective you describe
incarnation
exactly that's why i believe in
reincarnation because i see it
everywhere around me
um so the reality is i'm not in the
slightest bit scared of death
um and i think that that's uh the
biggest blessing that i got from doing
ayahuasca was no fear of death
um because that's a potent powerful
feeling not feeling
like knowledge insight right that's
categorically so quick for me to answer
that question and no
um it helped me deal with the you know
death of my father when my mum got
cancer it helped me come to terms with
what might happen
to not have her around as well this is
life
people die so you have to approach it
right you can't pretend that isn't going
to happen it's the only thing that's
guaranteed
so having a philosophical understanding
of what that means to you and then how
that impacts your life or maybe holds
you back
is a terrible thing so it's usually a
fear of death
that essentially limits our life in my
view
i i feel the exact same and the
experience i described to you where i
lost my
faith in christianity at 18 was also the
exact moment where
i um because up until that point i
believe that there's heaven and
there's a heaven and hell and that was a
[ __ ] terrifying thing so for the next
two years i went on this search of what
the answers were got obsessed with
reading about atheist books and it was
actually richard dawkins that said
um you can you should really fall in
love with the beauty of
of the world and like the true nature of
nature he talks about being able to go
into a church
and crying even as an atheist because of
the beauty and the wonder
but also on the point of death he's one
of the questions one of the things he
said was
a lot of people are scared of death
because it's the unknown and they and
when you're religious you think it's i'm
gonna burn
or i'm gonna be in this place with all
these good people that sound kind of
boring
but when you when i got to the point
where i was agnostic or atheist or
whatever you want to call it
he said like how did you feel a hundred
years ago was that i didn't
didn't feel anything were you scared
were you were you fearful no no because
i wasn't here and he said that's how
you'll feel then
and then like that when i lost the the
this idea that i would burn or go to
or you know go to this other place and
be judged in some way it all became
about now and it was
as you described it was this liberating
feeling of then okay well this is it if
this is it then i
i you know everything is so much more
special this isn't an audition
this is the [ __ ] show and my life
completely changed and i
i i i i completely agree i i asked the
question
which is a strange thing to ask in like
what i don't know what you really want
to call this a business podcast
because it's so fundamental to me and
because i think the fear of death is so
deeply illogical and as you say
imprisoning it's like
yeah so listen we've had we could talk
for hours and hours and hours
um what an amazing conversation
i'm so thankful for for you for coming
on and sharing your insights you know
it's interesting because the dan that
didn't want to do personal branding was
like oh well
you know i have a direct to consumer
product and what's my personal brand fit
in that but the most
convincing sales pitch for this product
was in fact when you talked about
you it's not when you you know you know
what i mean yeah and i think that
i mean of course like you talking about
the struggles you've had and the
agenda and motivations that went into
creating
your product is the most convincing
thing yeah and that's again why your
personal brand and you building it and
even why it's having this conversation
is so
i think so incredibly important um i
always finish this podcast
asking one question which i'm sure
you've had before which is about the
dinner party we're at a nice table now
just imagine there was two
other seats at this table who would you
bring to the table and why
your arms crossed again yeah sorry i'm
just getting into the serious mode like
thinking about this okay
um so
i think um i think to be honest
i'd want like an ancient philosopher
like i'd love like you know just be
so cool like marcus aurelius i would say
one big fan of meditations um you know
stoic philosophy
i read meditations um after my first
business fail someone bought it for me
um and i read it again every year it
takes like an hour to read and it's just
such a great reminder of
you know yes the world is tough and yes
the world is [ __ ] but everything is what
you make of it and
really the world you're living in is all
it all exists inside your own mind
and once you understand that you can
control a lot of how you feel
so marcus aurelius would be one and i
would say the second
you know this is pathetic and i'm sorry
but you know dennis bergkamp is my
all-time hero
i'm laguna um and you know the man was a
magician
and so classy and such a authentic and
great leader in so many ways
and iconic i feel though i hear huh
fearful
fearful oh yeah oh the opposite of jesus
he won't fly but he does walk on water
crazy when i heard that that he refused
to fly yeah yeah you're right yeah yeah
yeah totally correct yeah he's got a
bunch of uh interesting anxieties yes i
could ask him about that maybe
get marcus and well exactly and if i had
a third um if you were being generous
to be honest with you okay so yeah
um oprah yeah why uh
literally just think she's phenomenal
yeah it felt stupid asking why
yeah i mean just in every way right as
in i just it's hard to pick a thing but
let's just say then because of personal
growth media brand
understanding wealth and leveraging your
wealth for
good and storytelling i mean i could
just go on like
you know her list is just ridiculous so
a hundred percent oprah
um and uh oh i don't know i feel like i
i feel like uh you know once the fourth
seat it's literally sitting
sitting where he would be my french
bulldog because he started sprinting
around attacking uh
imaginary other french bulldog yeah
exactly pablo
um and then um i'd actually say my
fourth would be lewis hamilton
um because i think what he's achieved
even before literally breaking a record
like a couple of weeks ago
um is so awesome and i love i'm so proud
of the fact that he's british
i'm so proud of the fact like obviously
even though i'm a white guy i'm so proud
of the fact of what he's doing to using
his platform to take a stance
actually being political with his
message when he knows he has such a big
platform which is a thing that a lot of
people choose not to do and choose to
back out of so
he's a man that stands for morals and
values secondly
um he's vegan so you know i like i think
it's interesting that he's chosen he's
gotten such a high performance
no fail like attitude but is like as a
plant-based person clearly
environmentally conscious even if he's
in f1 which is obviously debatable
but um he's got these like clearly deep
rooted values about how he wants
uh the world to be and he is manifesting
and living them in being
basically the greatest racing driver
that's ever ever lived that's what he
will end up as because he just beat
schumacher's record
um and he seems like quite a nice bloke
just in general like i just like when i
see interviews of him
i just like what a relatable guy that
says you know he doesn't seem like a
knob superstar at all
so i would just love to the reason for
him is i just love to talk to him about
mindset
and focus because when you think about
it that is
all you're doing in an f1 car yeah that
is the
in my opinion the most focused you can
be is driving formula one
i don't think there is any other i don't
think i don't think anything tops that
so i would love to know how you achieve
that kind of level of flow and focus
like week in week out nothing would be
more interesting so marcus
berkamp oprah and uh sounds like a
wicked dinner
yeah hamilton sounds amazing listen
thank you so much for your time today
it's a pleasure to consider your friend
uh a mentor through the content you
produce in your podcast secret leaders
but also just an all-around good guy
and um you you're you have a a way of
being
honest and open which was not only
perfect for this podcast but it's so
tremendously valuable for people like me
for everybody listening and i want to
thank you for that as well because it's
not always
the the the easiest thing to do you know
people default to
massaging the ego or trying to get you
know press for
being positive and and untouchable and
perfect and i think you've taken a
different route which is serving
a much needed uh positive service to
to the world so thank you for that as
well and pleasure yeah i'm sure
you will uh pick up this conversation
again soon thank you so much for
listening to this episode of the diary
of a ceo
listen if you're on the podcast store or
you're in spotify or you're listening to
it in some kind of app
do me a huge huge favor leave a review
and hit the subscribe button
if you're watching this on youtube right
now i need another favor i need you to
hit the like button
and if you'd be so generous to leave a
comment one person that does this
will be joining me in march at the diary
of a ceo live show
in manchester and you'll be coming
backstage and meeting me and the other
members of our team
thank you so much for listening and i'll
see you again next monday
[Music]